What do you think, David?
>> So just like last time we'll set
that the goal is to get the batter out
via pitching.
And we'll add the necessary information
to our current working memory, but
when we get down here
something confusing happens.
So we suggest
the throw-curve-ball operator
because our goal is to pitch and
the batter isn't out.
But then, we also suggest they throw
a fast ball operator because the goal is
to pitch, the batter's not out and
the batter bats left-handed.
So, when we get down to rule seven,
which is if only one operator has
been selected, it doesn't fire.
So our current rules don't
actually lead anywhere.
We never bottom out.
We never figure out what we want to do.
>> Good David.
That was the correct answer.
So note what has happened?
So far we had assumed that
the match between the percept and
the production rules captioning the
personal knowledge was such that, given
the percept we always have one rule
which will tell us what action to take.
It may take some time
to get to this rule.
Some rules may need to be established.
And then only so
the rules get established,
then only we get the action.
But never the less,
the system would work.
The difficulty now is,
there is no rule which tells us
exactly what action to take.